this process of the balance of right
boundaries and right compassion there is
no algorithm for it to get it right
there isn't like a general rule of thumb
that is always the right answer it it's
it's something you actually have to
think about and feel into each situation
the instantiation of that situation and
you wrestle with it
[Music]
there are plenty of times where someone
does the tough love thing to a friend or
a family member that has addiction going
on and that's what it took for the
person to finally turn around plenty of
other times where someone does the tough
love thing and the person who just goes
and kills themselves and that same
person had they got to support it
another therapy or rehab clinic or
whatever could have turned around and so
what the right answer is is not like if
you have a very fast default it's
probably wrong it's something that you
have to really take the time to reflect
in to what is actually called for here
and then reflect into what are my biases
am i biasing and they I don't want to
take their burden on or biasing and the
codependent I must take it on direction
that's going to make me less clear it
makes me think about the is an old
distinction that you brought up and also
about what self development is at it's
very core which is trying to model an
effective way to operate within the
world it's trying to make as scientific
as possible the way that you behave the
way that I behave sometimes the way that
we behave there's books about
relationships and friendship and and and
stuff like that but mostly it tends to
be personal sovereignty upward mobility
agency stuff like that but as you've
just identified there in that situation
like there is no one-size-fits-all there
is no objective way to decide what the
life that you should lead is what your
definition of a good life is it's got a
shaky foundation evolutionarily it's got
a very biased foundation culturally and
socially you know that is what we're
trying to achieve what is the best way
for me to operate within this world but
there is no there is no Universal answer
to that this better end is worse but
better by who worse by who you know you
can you can run this back as far as you
want yeah so I would say that
wisdom is not algorithmic and cannot be
made algorithmic you can't have a if
this then that algorithm that actually
equals wisdom and and if you can then
we're just a intermediate bootloader for
the AIS that are better creatures than
us right I could actually go through
some long derivations as to why I think
consciousness is not computational not
purely computational but there's
something happening in consciousness
that is fundamentally trans
computational so strong computationalism
is the idea that computation is both
necessary and sufficient for
consciousness mind and universe and I
believe that's false
so there is something to the nature of
choice and this also good choice ethics
that can be informed by lots of
different principles and considerations
but not perfectly prescribed
and this is why at lower stages of
development when people can't hold as
much complexity and as much nuance with
as much awareness sometimes they need
just simple rules to not go off the
rails so you think of the 10
commandments as rules like that right if
you need to know don't kill anybody and
don't rape anybody and don't adulterer
and whatever like okay will tell you
those things don't do that like the
society will be better if people don't
do those things but then you notice New
Testament comes along and Jesus gives a
different kind of teaching right do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you love thy neighbor as thyself
it actually doesn't tell you what to do
it isn't a do something or don't do
something it's actually consider
something a certain way so try to put
yourself into the shoes of whoever
you're about to act and ask how you
would feel engage in empathy
so it's an ethic that guides the
guidance is consider something but not
do this or don't do that so it's
ultimately not prescriptive
but there's still wisdom that can be
offered so there's a lot of kind of
general principles that we can offer
that support wisdom but it's not
reducible to prescription now this is
also something about personal
development if one is wanting to grow in
wisdom as it doesn't look like do this
thing
and so you also can't signal it very
effectively by doing a particular thing
[Music]
I mean someone could even try to signal
aligned with what I just said right they
could say let me consider that as just
some kind of signaling but that what I'm
talking about like is a depth of
earnestness of what do I actually care
about and why do I care about it and how
do I reflect on what I believe to be
both true and meaningful right now and
what is right action factoring what I
understand to be true and what I
understand to be meaningful and how
certain am I on what I think is true and
how bias am I and what I think is
meaningful and can I refine those as
well
[Music]
you